what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey this is
unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone do we just become best
friends yep
hello everybody welcome back to another
episode of the unwaxed
podcast with your favorite sisters
sophia and sistine stallone
breaking news guys big big news big news
if anyone's noticed we actually changed
the cover art
for our podcast you guys we glowed up
it looks loaded and i have to give
credit to cysteine because
you put in the time you put in the work
and i made it so
please no one make fun of it i i think
it looks great i think it stands out way
more than the other one did oh
i'm gonna be honest i think the other
one was done
very very quick poorly and quickly and
just just not enough it wasn't right
just not great this one
is in your face you know what just like
we are just screams on waxed
yes in every sense of the word happy
tuesday everybody
thank you for checking in and tuning in
again guess what
what i blew up on tick tock
well who knew i have always said
that i was never going to get a tick
tock i would never do tick tocks i would
always be a part of sistine's production
because she puts in
a lot of effort to create good ones but
i was like you know what
she had a tick tock blow up why don't i
just do it and i'll do what she does
and use our dad for clout so and did it
work
like a charm worked i have 2 million
views
almost 500 000 likes on it i mean your
numbers are cute
they're cute cestine's had her tick tock
since before kovitz started
i've already gained 40 000 followers 60
million views
but two is cute like you're doing great
so rude
you're doing so great sweetie she
literally complimented me yesterday
saying wow you actually have like a lot
more
on the way here i know oh was it on the
way here
yeah finally after by the way i posted
this a week ago and she
finally is acknowledging going oh wow
you actually got a lot more than i
thought
thank you thank you proud of you yeah
but you know what
how do you feel turning 25 that you're
on tick tock
i just you know i have like one more
year before you're really striking
nerves
right now i don't know what happened to
your brain fog that just like
short-circuited you i just
hybrid i just jekyll and hide it myself
right now
well you just do juggle and hide it
yourself yeah i'm making that a thing
jekyll and hyded myself what is that
means i just switched people i was
really nice when i came in here the
second we hit record
i became a monster a lot nicer actually
debatable debatable but you know what
i've kind of realized about
tick tock and i think just social media
is the pressure
and the desire to get that flow back it
was so weird because right after it blew
up i was thinking
i need to make a good one i need to take
a better one hold you
and it's stressful it's so stressful
before i was never on the app now i'm
constantly looking for sounds and trying
to be quirky
and funny but not cringey and i'm like
what the [ __ ] am i doing
i don't know that's something i don't
blame these people
that are so productive i mean it works
it works at first i didn't really
trying to chase that high those
endorphins of oh my god i need to get
another hit
i know really toxic it's really toxic
i'm already at like five hours on my
phone every sunday when they say that
you know have you ever seen those on
sunday your phone pops up like how much
screen time you've had
i've already had that much that is not a
big concern that is not good that mine
is going to shoot up a bit more
but i do it for the followers i do it
for the fans and i do it for the clout
so do it for you guys we're going to
blame you guys for that
um in other news mother's day is
approaching
and again no one knew yeah when mother's
day was like myself
it's may 9th yeah may 9th it's one of
those days that kind of just sneak up on
you out of nowhere yeah just like
father's
day yeah it's it's underrated but really
important
i feel like a mother's day it's one of
those holidays that just makes me
love being on instagram because everyone
will post just the hottest
throwback of their mom and every guy's
like oh my god milf milford really
literally think about it
on mother's day or father's day i have
never had that thought
this is what people do like you post the
best photo that your mom has ever taken
in her
entire life maybe she's in her 20s like
doing a test photo shoot
or whatever and then it'll just yeah
you've never seen that no i've seen it
i've just never thought of it that way
that people just post the hottest photos
of their mom well they do
yeah yeah well i was thinking about the
obviously about mother's day gifts
that's what i'm a little worried about
okay
what are you worried about what what do
you get your mom
especially our mom which she doesn't
have i mean i feel like we've tried
we've given her makeup we've done the
breakfast in bed which i think we're
still gonna do we're gonna take her to
dinner
and of course you can do the personal
cards and handwritten letters
but i don't know it's so tough because
it's
i don't know well we planned we we are
going to do a brunch for her we're going
to make her breakfast in bed which we do
every single year right but how do you
get a woman that literally brought you
into this world
a gift that could be equivalent to that
hours and hours
of labor and pain and 25 years and you
give her
a gift card to sephora like what can you
say what can you give this person
there's no
object in the world so it's going to be
tough hopefully
you know she'll like our little special
things easter eggs that will
hide yeah maybe we'll check that her in
the morning like with
us to walk the dogs and bring her back
breakfast
and do that stuff jennifer i hope you're
not disappointed with the outcome
we're gonna really we're gonna really
try we're gonna really try
um the funniest thing happened to me the
other day sophia
i was on a walk actually less funny more
emotional why i was on a walk
and i look over to my right and i see
maybe it was a little creepy of me but i
was looking
in someone's home hmm
it's not weird but you know i mean i i
like i
like glance at nearby homes and i see oh
yeah this particular home really caught
my eye
i look inside and i see this super super
super old man
okay in a full-on tuxedo like
bow tie he looks like a penguin like
really cute he's hunched over and he has
a walker
and then he leaves
my view and grabs his wife this old old
lady in a beautiful ball gown dress
and they're just on their walkers
together and i i don't know why
i just got so in my feels they literally
looked like the couple from
up like just so cute and i
instantly go oh my god i want a
boyfriend
that made me want a relationship i i
would want to
i didn't i say this to you the other day
i'm like i just want the cuddle i want
that feel of
you know i dress up for a date night
it's super sweet
but that's what you want in the future
oh i really wish i saw that
it was so freaking cute and he was like
complimenting her and then he spun her
like i'm not
kidding you when i say i literally shot
my heart out because it was so adorable
love isn't dead love isn't dead love
isn't dead it isn't dead that just
proved it because you know i've been
i brought this up to sistine the other
day because i was
i'm just thinking about boys not men
boys and the way they text
they have a certain style of texting
that just drives me nuts
go on okay i said that guys use whenever
they're about to talk
have i don't know if anyone's ever
experienced this but when you're having
a texting
conversation with a guy and or maybe
it's someone that you used to talk
to or it's next whatever or it's someone
you're trying to ghost
and they're trying to reach back out or
say something uncomfortable
or trying to make it less awkward they
usually send something that
is an uncomfortable sentence and then
the emoji that follows is
always the same emoji it's the upside
down smiley face
or the clown emoji yes do you know what
i'm talking about okay
those two emojis are unacceptable
are absolutely unacceptable if a guy
says something cringey that he knows is
cringy and he probably shouldn't be
texting
you that anyway and then follows it with
an upside down smiley face
the blow doesn't lessen it's still
just as awkward probably even more no
but it's like you're doing that because
you know what you're saying is so
weird and embarrassing and awkward so
don't send it you're making it worse
you're just like
you're putting the stamp of approval but
that this text should not have been sent
by sending it what what are the what is
that i when i because i remember i
mentioned this to sistine i went on a
tangent about
what because i she i think a guy sent
that to her
and then i was like wait that's
hilarious because someone sent that to
me the other day
and we realized i think that's a pattern
with them it's just like guys do two
things they send
uncomfortable messages with that upside
down and smiley face and they send a lot
of photos
yeah okay i would love to get into that
for a second really quick
why do guys send selfies of themselves
all the time or or location where they
are
i get selfies up the hoo-ha i get
so many selfies and my question is i
don't
reciprocate with the photo nor did i ask
for one but my theory is
do they think that they're so attractive
that they want you to see how attractive
that they are
so they send a selfie i don't i don't
know what it is because it's not only
selfies but i've had guys
i i think every single guy i've talked
to they've sent
a photo or video of the current location
they're at
or maybe a quick selfie and then turns
it into whatever
that's different that's fine for example
i think there's something i don't do no
no no that's different see if they're
sending something quirky
like them in a funny outfit or them
with a good caption to go with it then
that's acceptable okay but if they say
hey
and then just send a straight on selfie
of themselves with it
i hate that that is unacceptable as well
yeah i i don't think i've oh no i've
gotten those i've gotten those
but i think it's the way guys flirt
because girl i mean
personally i've never just sent a selfie
first of all ballsy because i know i'll
need the lighting
the hair the makeup the mood like i
can't just be sudden selfies randomly
when i come out well i have to be we
need the ring lighting i need the fog
machine behind us yes
we need uh i need the paris filter on
our face
i need in person that you see the two
love layers of foundation stuck on my
face
because i don't have any blemishes as
far as he's concerned as far as he's
concerned
blush just a natural flush my lashes are
this thick
yes and my nose is just twinkling at the
tip
oh my god maybe we're just so picky
and that is why we are so sick no we're
just we always say we're catfish i just
think that we
like to make sure we look good i don't
want to send some
i don't know i don't want to sound like
a gross you can see me gross in the
morning
later we don't even need to worry about
the sofia because we're having a hot
girl summer
we are true ladies and gentlemen
we are this is the ultimate hot girl
summer we always
we talked about in the past but i think
this year
is going to be i'm gonna really try to
be
i'm so bipolar i swear a second ago i
just said
i really want a boyfriend and now i'm
about to say i really am going to try to
be single
what is wrong with me right now because
it's hot girl summer and we're getting
you back to
it's true i'm pushing you away from your
fields and we're going to get more i was
about to join a dating app last night
were you i really yes i was no
times desperate times i would have told
you absolutely
you know it's bad when you didn't even
tell me about it that's when you know
it's bad
but i've deleted and re-downloaded the
same app
four times oh
sistine that's kind of it's a little
yeah no i know i say the word do it
doesn't it thanks sophia you know i'm
aware
i don't blame you i don't blame you you
know we're gonna thrive this summer i
think
this is the time we're going to get into
shape like what are you going to do to
get into hot girl summer
hmm what are your tips and tricks
because i know what i'm going to do
i think i need to be more consistent
with
like shaving my legs and
and i need to become more consistent
with that flossing my teeth and
whitening you know i really would like
to be more consistent with shaving my
legs and
um yeah what are things we're lacking
the top of this because everyone knows
hot girl summer overall
it revolves around dieting and eating
healthy
and working out and dyeing your hair to
make it perfect but what are things oh
we're pretty i think we're pretty much
we're we've always been that way
naturally but what are things that we're
lacking to make us even more higher
than we're shaving yeah shaving we are
unwaxed
so we're going to stay on brand
all right we're going to shave our
uh what else legs else i'm trying to
think uh uh uh
we need to start exfoliating the
previous
layer of fake tan that we had left on a
week prior
i'm gonna start working on exfoliating
my arms okay exfoliate your arms because
it gets like reactions from
some lotion hypoallergenic lotions
okay i think i'm gonna start sleeping on
a silk pillowcase i heard those are
great for you
yeah i don't feel like everyone does
those sick pillow cases i don't know
what that does
maybe i'll yeah maybe i'll start you
know
doing some hair masks and
okay cool cool hot girl summer putting
on some spf
that's all i got to say perfect okay if
you guys smell like sunscreen
yeah okay well if you guys uh
needed some hot girl summer tips thanks
for joining and
wait so why do you want a hot girl
summer
because the last summer was coveted
summer
and i haven't i've been what is your
grand master plan
for hot girl summer yeah like are you
gonna go out on the town and just be
like
i'm gonna have the balls to go up to
anyone i've done that
naturally first of all [ __ ]
are you kidding do we want to get into
this you know
i have the confidence to go up to
anybody in this room
right now you're laughing because you
know no because i'm laughing that i'm
the only one why are you lying to our
listeners i'm not lying
i'm not lying so seeing you're just you
know when liars lie their voices change
octaves i'm not lying
you know so i remember i was on a date
and a guy um called me out for this
because
the waitress came over to ask what we
wanted to eat and
i talked normally like this and when she
asked i go
oh i would really like the salad i do
this thing
and he she walks away and the guy goes
why what happened what happened and i
literally go i go what
it's like what you what and he goes your
voice
literally changed i do the same thing
when i order
my voice goes up yeah can i just get the
salmon please oh my
gosh thank you so much for the water oh
my god thank you so much
so funny it's so unconscious but i just
think hot girl summer we just
go out it everyone get vaccinated and
let's go do it
live our best life live our best life um
sistine yes
why am i reading that you went on an
omegle again
why why why are you
throwing me under the bus when you were
with me
what well i wasn't with you sophia
sophia you don't remember the
the giant anaconda that popped up on the
screen you weren't there for that oh
you guys you know what i'm not a weirdo
doing this alone i said sophia the other
day
the app again so there is no app so
fact-checked yourself
i'm about to fight her in the studio
literally no i said to you the other day
i said sophia want to go on a megal and
you go
yes and you sat there with me did i
black out or something i mean
and then you're like oh she did it alone
you're not
no okay you're coming down with me
forgot i forgot is that dust is that i
mean
i remember i started doing that in the
beginning you did it so much in the
beginning during covid and i thought it
was the weirdest thing and now i just
kind of sat in the background now i'm
sitting right up front
and now i'm never joining again because
of what we saw the giant
i can't we call it a anaconda [ __ ]
pencil
gross person doing that to kids
i don't know we typed in tick-tock too
and that's what came up of course he
knew exactly who to catch you
i wanted a bad bleep and i got that yeah
i got that
i got that oh in other news um
okay so i'm just gonna give you guys a
week by week
florida animal sighting update because
this just
keeps happening more articles keep
popping up of just obscure
and even very animated about this first
turtle on the sidewalk
then velociraptor in the front yard true
now
what's now you guys aren't ready i'm not
i think maybe
tons of articles came out yeah with the
headline
nearly 144 000
genetically modified mosquitoes are
going to be released in florida
what yeah why yeah that sounds horrible
wait yeah
who who's releasing this um
i i don't know for the state of florida
is just deciding to
release so it's in an effort to reduce
the population of a mosquito
species that can spread dangerous
diseases like
zika virus and yellow fever okay wait
that's kind of
oh yeah but what if i
oh okay i i know exactly what this is
i think i've read something about this
where they're able to almost procreate
with them
and then they kill them off is that kind
of how it is because i know that crispr
and those
genetic modifiers i just had about jeans
can do that the first thing that came to
my head was
those tracker jackers from hunger games
oh no these are supposed to be
helping you guys know what i'm talking
about i know what you're talking about
those things are scary you get bit by
one of these genetically modified
tracker jackers and you're just dead do
you think you could win the hunger games
no what would know your strategy i've
always free
okay as high as i can yeah but then they
send
they'll burn the tree down or send a bee
up and i just try to
do be like tarzan and jump to the next
tree see i don't know
full disguise like a mustache or where
you're going to find a hat and a cane
and
jump in the morning i turned into the
monopoly man
uh no i would like fully cover myself in
mud
and and twig and trees and just be a
shrub
and just so you fully rambo it
i would ramble that now you're like i
can't believe we just even used that as
a reference
it's okay i think it's appropriate
honestly i feel like everyone's gonna
really pick up on this one
yep when he like blended into the wall
and he came out as like a mud man
you know he's really eager to come on
this podcast yeah
you know how funny this is yeah he
really really really wants i mean not
that that's a surprise
actually it is a surprise he was you
know he wanted to come on
yeah no we're excited to have a mom we
just wanna
i think i'm i'm nervous yeah but he's
been i think it's more so he's been very
adamant about really coming on and
you know we were really i think mom we
were super nervous to have on
because she is our biggest critic yeah
i'm
really nervous to have dad on because i
think that
people have been waiting for this one
specifically forever
and we just genuinely want to make sure
that the
things that we bring on and ask him are
good like things that people haven't
asked him that he'd be more open to
talking about or i don't know
man it'll be a good one so i know you
guys are always asking about it he's
going to come on
it'll be a good episode we're seeing a
daughter father-daughter
interview session i don't think so
seeing it here don't think so
um oh should we talk about what we've
been binging on
oh oh yeah i think during quarantine
we've gone
through so many binge tv show phases
every single trash reality show we've
seen we've conquered
and we've prospered from absolutely now
our current obsession is
married at first sight you guys this
show
is tv magic i was already on this
bandwagon before
there's probably 28 seasons and my
recommendation is
google best seasons worst to best best
of worst
and start from there you guys literally
strangers do not see each other
until they are walking down the altar
yeah what the hell yeah i don't i don't
know
i would have a panic attack i would
absolutely be the person that says
i can't do it and out of all of us who
do you think would do it
any you you think i would marry a
stranger
yeah i do oh why do i think so as well i
don't know why i feel like you scarlett
i
don't think she would i think she still
wants to have fun with her friends
she's awesome i'm pitching me i'm
picturing this girl as an 18 year old
like a
child bride going a child bro but as
older yeah i don't i
my mindset isn't there but it's a really
really good show i know we've talked
about so many reality shows like love
island go check that out if you haven't
temptation island are you the one
great one but this one is really good
because if you want something a little
bit
not as it's drama but not so much
splashing drinks in your face and you
know
it's not like cup recoupling and things
like that it's really just one-on-one
relationship
actually how you go through a marriage
in the beginning you imagine
yeah you walk down the aisle you're
facing your husband
and you say hi what's your name i don't
and then you have to spend the night
together what if he what if you're not
attracted to him what do you do
and use this is what's happening in the
season we're watching the guy is
literally saying to the girl
i'm not attracted to you first of all
that is so
rude i know well wait he's being honest
but then get out
you know i hate that maybe i'm being i
don't know maybe i'm being like a
a pessimist but i think if if the guy
said to me
i'm not interested in you or sexually
attracted to you i'd be like okay then
this probably isn't gonna work well i
feel like
you're signing up for this show
not for the super hot
partner you're going to end up with but
for a genuine
deeper connection with someone right
that you'd want to spend your life with
that's why you're doing it because
obviously you don't care about looks if
you're willing to marry
a complete stranger that may or may not
be your type so for you to say
oh actually i'm just not attracted to
you but you said in the interviews that
you
wanted someone to connect with and blah
blah and she's such a great girl
she's a great girl well you realize in
the show that
the way that they match people up are
basically okay from
whatever they say appearance-wise like i
want someone that has
i'm really attracted to blondes and i
really like
this but everything is your morals
it's crazy that's what they try to pair
it up but these guys
are lying you guys guys the guys on this
season
are so manipulative it's just to get on
tv
these men go to these interviews
pitch themselves of why they would be a
great husband he goes yeah
i'm loyal and i just want that person
that i can just wake up to next to you
every day
and and blah blah blah and they're going
wow this guy seems like a wonderful
person
then when the cameras aren't rolling
they're screaming at producers saying f
u
f this f this mer like being such
[ __ ] the cameras go back on
i never did any of that oh yeah and then
the other guy saying um
off air if we don't have sex on our
honeymoon this isn't gonna work
and then they're at the meeting and
she's like i swear to god the only thing
i'm upset about is you saying that he's
like i never said that
but isn't that scary because that a lot
of people have that
yeah a lot of people have that i
remember i went on a date with that one
guy
oh this is a story time for for later
but we went on five dates
he was the greatest guy my type was
funny
then all the sudden date number five hit
and a
flip i would honestly if you're ever
comfortable talking about that story i
think you can just very much
generalize it so you don't have to get
too specific no i definitely want to
talk about it but
i think a lot of girls need to hear this
because even when i heard it
it reminds me of holy [ __ ]
guys can be very i mean girls can be too
but
so when you're dating a guy you really
don't know who you're going out that's
why you don't point like
it really changes first of all it takes
you out it freaks you out but it also
changes you from that point on in the
way that you approach basically every
dating situation because if that hadn't
happened to me
i would go into every relationship with
a guy
with this sort of you know rose-colored
glasses like
colored lens exactly oh my god but that
just brings me to
you know how we talked about in a few
episodes back haunted clothing
yeah oh yeah yeah and that how what did
you have
clothing we refer to as when you wear a
certain outfit
and on that day you wore the outfit it
was a really really
bad day yeah so like you've had a bad
date and so you just forget about that
clothing and never work it's just so
weird that this is all coming full
circle right now because
i wore last night we went to dinner yeah
and the dress that i wore to dinner was
the dress that i wore on that fifth date
with that guy oh my god
and i ran into my room after yeah and i
haven't worn
you guys i haven't worn that dress since
i'm not kidding maybe i'm so dramatic
but i put this dress back on and i felt
i know
it just instantly reminded me of this
person that i haven't thought of in
forever
and i that just brought back so many
memories of you wearing that dress funny
i've never wanted to get into my car and
kill someone
i swear we're going to talk about it i
promise you guys we will talk about it
like such a crazy
if i ever see this [ __ ] oh my god i
am going we're gonna just
let you know if i ever see you if i ever
see you face to face
you know how i said i was joking if that
had punched someone
this time i'm not joking this time i'm
not joking hey you
can you i love it can you have some i
love it she's looking at me
like oh god like no i'm just kidding i
love it i love the support
i am but that that dress uh
just reminded me of so many things that
like exes can ruin for you
yeah and i'm not saying that he was an
ex but when you have some a bad memory
associated to a thing or
song or restaurant it bothers me so much
that i can't ever do or listen to those
things anymore because it reminds me of
that shitty person yeah
it does but not even sometimes it
doesn't even need to be a shitty person
sometimes it's just something
that you did with your ex even if you
love them that
it just brings up so many old emotions
that you're like i can't listen to it
because it's going to make me it's like
oh my god my ex
like used to play tennis and now
every time i play fetch with the dog it
just reminds me of my exes
triggering like wait so true for you
um do you have like a one song yes i
have one song that bothers me so much
because it's from the 1975.
somebody else my favorite band and it's
such a beautiful song
but i hate the person tied to it so
much yeah you have one yeah but my
you're gonna laugh at mine
okay what okay because mine's not a bad
one but
um you know the song caroline
she's like that big that thanks that is
wait why what i can't listen to without
feeling a little like
that's your song well can i explain so
because i remember um that was probably
the first time i was in
like a long car ride with my ex and i
think the song
just came out and it for some reason we
just like
looked at each other we're like this is
such a good song and i just remember
like blasting it
laughing so hard i think that was the
moment we like looked each other like
this is gonna really work and you know
it's not because of the song the song
has no ambiance of being romantic
at all but it's just like it's such a
happy memory but every time i think
about it and play the song i think about
that car ride every single time and him
see god thanks a lot
sir such a good song
okay sophia i have brought in
a bedtime story
[Music]
christine i'm so excited to hear what
you brought in today it's um
because i don't really know what you
brought in at all i wasn't actually even
planning on bringing in a bedtime story
i don't know
why you know sometimes when you sit in
bed and
just weird memories and come up at two
in the morning yeah
and i just had a little chuckle at two
in the morning is it one of those
memories though where you think back
and it physically makes you cringe oh
absolutely oh
but it's it's it's been so long that
it's just funny to laugh about now
okay let's hear it all right let's go
back in time
to maybe when i was 17
18 years old right oh young sistine just
a
little chicken nugget um i'm going to
share the story of
maybe top three worst makeouts
of my life wait we've both brought in a
bedtime story with our worst makeout
you brought one in two remember how i
made out that guy and i locked myself in
the stairwell
and he had to get me out after i ran out
of the room
oh i thought it was more of a date no i
made out with him and it was so bad
i ran to the stairwell well i locked
myself in and got to get me out
i think i beat you really i don't know i
don't know why but now i think about it
i think i've had
more bad kisses than good kids why don't
people know how to kiss
it's one of those basic techniques that
is so overlooked
i'm sorry if you don't know how to kiss
no but it's true it's almost like
the basics are the foundation for the
whole rest of the evening
how can you mess that up completely
honest
if you're a bad kisser it kind of deters
me from
being more 100 and i don't want it to
like ruin everything but
i mean let me i know let me show you
that
it's gonna it's gonna gross you out
honestly it's gonna gross you out so i
was it was my
movie was my second boyfriend um and it
lasted all of
three weeks oh three weeks you guys it
was really cute it was really cute um
no he's a sweet guy but this is just a
really funny story so
i remember i it was like our second kiss
and i was kissing him
and all of a sudden i feel like
like water had just splashed on my face
or like wet was all over my
face and i was like what and i put my
hand on my face and i looked down it was
blood and i was like covered in blood
and
and he looks up and he had these crazy
eyes like holy [ __ ] and i'm like
holy [ __ ] so we both run to the bathroom
and i was like you got a [ __ ] nose
bleed on me
and he had the audacity
to blame me and my nose
so we spent the next 10 minutes in the
bathroom mirror
looking up each other's nostrils trying
to figure out whose nose
bled on who was it his for sure a
hundred percent had never gotten a
nosebleed in my life and he was like
so accustomed to getting a nosebleed
i've never gone into and he's still
to this day will not admit nor apologize
blamed me for the nosebleed and
to make matters worse i thought about it
a bit more that
that happened to me three times with
three separate guys
cysteine are you actually seeing i'm not
even lying i've had three men
nosebleed on me making out yeah i have
that is disgustingly thank you the
weirdest thing
i have ever heard in my entire life i
have never made out with a guy
and one of us get a nosebleed
mid-makeout you've had it three times
brag that's not a humble brag that is
humble flex
is that crazy i don't know what it is
it's sweet do you just like
do you just make guys noses really maybe
i make them light-headed
yeah and they just i don't know maybe
with power but it was
me guys you know can you imagine that
that's my superpower i'm making yourself
on me um but yeah that was i looked like
carrie so you've
tasted three different boys blood
yeah i'm basically vampire at this point
i feel like you
that's probably what it is so wait so
you're telling me three different times
you've made out with guys they've had
nosebleeds on you
and you've had to stop and go check and
wipe it off
well so the other two the other guys
admitted that it was there so i went to
go fix it what do you
what do you do i can tell you their
names they'll know who they are
oh my god wait i would love to hear
after but um
after that you do after after that
instance um i would say
safe to say that the mood was ruined and
it was sort of hard to pick up where we
left off
so i went home i called my mom and she
picked me up
honestly like blood when it's not
my own oh my god it's not and imagine it
all over your
face your mouth like oh no remember that
the remember this the mosquito thing
when i you i whacked the mosquito at my
head and i
how that was on my face tiny bit of but
that made me want to throw up
can you imagine i was making out with
someone and my teeth just started to
stain red
because of someone's [ __ ] nose it was
bad that's
nasty that is nasty
okay i get it christina she's like you
are disgusting not
you but like who are you going out
that's my question
oh that's even worse
i would there's like certain guys i'm
like maybe they could have a nosebleed
on me
i'll let it pass this one i would not
let it that was an
unacceptable nosebleed i know oh see i
think i beat your stairwell story
yeah i mean i would rather be locked in
the stairwell and have the guy that i
ran away from trying to get me out
more than right haven't bleed on me
right i feel like this whole podcast
theme
so far has been um [ __ ] on on guys
not really shitty taco summer that we're
already getting started
oh that was a good one thank you that's
nasty but great remember if you guys
want to submit your bedtime stories
to the unwax podcast you can write in
our dms you can send it in the email
that we have in our bio
literally anywhere we check every sort
of messaging platform that you guys try
to reach out to us on
so please submit your story and we'll
read it on the show we did that with one
girl
a few weeks back and it was hilarious so
we love hearing them so please
and we have our email so email us i said
that
um no i was just gonna say for other
inquiries too and so if you want to work
with us
if you have some yeah stories or
questions and things like that
your beaver you are just that end at
anything
i like hearing from you why you look
stuffed
today i don't know what's going on with
me all right
so um cysteine wrote this as an idea
you guys are gonna laugh at this because
this is just my personality in a
in another i thought what could be a
topic that sofia
would just take and sprint with it well
so she wrote down this
this title and i just was like i was
just gonna
bullet point and just fly off the handle
and think of ideas
i haven't done all these like these are
some of them are kind of insane but
i've also also we asked our girlfriends
yes
our girlfriends contributed but let me
just preface really quick
i said sophia my computer died write
down a few ideas
when it charges back up i'll add some
more
when i returned to this google doc
to see nearly an entire page i'm not
exaggerating
an entire page of bullets
consisting of different stocking
techniques
i don't know if i was extremely proud of
you
or extremely concerned but i i'm gonna
say proud
i was very proud of this little stalker
sophia over here thank you
um i just have you know why i have loved
research like i will we're gonna call it
research no seriously i i'm a
you and everyone in my family knows this
i don't do anything without looking it
up we all made fun of me for
like looking up the menu before going to
a restaurant sometimes
and checking in with my ex through
finsta
all that stuff so i have been shameless
about it but
sistine said stalking techniques and i
feel like a lot of people have some
ideas but i was like okay i'm just gonna
shoot some that i think would work
and i i'm not gonna tell you which ones
i've used but you know
we thought take for take what you want
these are so these are a mixture between
me and sistine and a bunch of girls
yes they're crazy yes we know they're
crazy guess what
they all work and they're fun so don't
come for us
so if you're seeing a guy for the first
time or a girl and
or you're dating a guy or a girl for the
first time and you just want to get to
know them a little bit
a little bit better a little bit better
yeah all right i'll shoot it
so use safari to go onto instagram
to see who they recently followed most
recently
so for some for some reason safari
specifically if you go to instagram
you can click on their following and who
they're following and it's the most
the most recent one didn't know that
yeah so you can see
if they're following some thoughts if
they're following their grandma
because guess what then you can go check
out her page i wouldn't want to know
she just what's the next one um facebook
is your friend i know i don't use
facebook anymore but it is your friend
so type their name
what happens if you get no results
justine i don't know what do you do
you dive into their family tree by just
typing in their last name you do that
for me
i have done that one time for this one i
am banned from facebook so i cannot use
this one yeah
for some reason someone keeps banning
her someone keeps blocking my account
for pretending to be me yeah why
odd i'm on facebook i mean she does look
fake but you know
you know you know
i'll see you in court hold on i'll see
you in court
you'll be hearing from my lawyer read
the next one all right um
youtube their name yep right sometimes
you can watch their
middle school soccer games their dad
uploaded in 2011.
okay this is funny because well i
remember i was going out with this guy
and he was more in social media-esque
world where he would think
he could this is years ago i'm not that
weird
um or like not years but like a year ago
not years maybe like four months
literally last an hour ago
oh no but it was a while back and i was
like oh like let me see if he
has done anything on youtube if he does
like youtube videos
and i saw a video of his like middle
school soccer game from did he win
2011 and his dad uploaded it
i don't know i watched the whole thing i
felt really weird that i found it and
then i remember on the days like yeah i
used to play soccer i was like oh
so he was like i had no idea i had no
idea and i was like i totally knew and
you were remembering you were on the
card number 18 right yeah number eight
yeah
i stopped doing that um another one an
obvious one i feel like a lot of my
friends said this one as well
venmo to see who they've been spending
time with yeah you use venmo the cash
app
i've done demo one before i haven't done
that i don't have venmo either so like
that one doesn't work for me as well
but my friend made it a point she was
saying that like you can see who their
friends are they're closer friends and
you can define a guy by who their five
closest friends are because that's
usually who they are
that's true you are who you hang out
with okay um that's
i feel like the easiest one that
everyone assumes is the fake instagram
easy right but you have to be careful
because obviously they'll catch on if
you have zero followers zero following
except for him
that's crazy so this is the thing let's
just say and this is for people maybe
if you want to know if your ex is
stalking your page you see a random
account that just keeps watching your
stories
just you're like this isn't this isn't
normal they have no followers they're
following a bunch of people
this is fishy this is fishy you click on
it you can
i don't know how specifically but i saw
this on tiktok you can find out their
contact information and so
it won't show the full email or the full
phone number but it will show part of it
it'll be like sofia
blank if it's yeah if it's my email or
if it's the last few days oh no yeah if
you have a specific way
i know oh no i know i know
so i think that and i don't use mine
anymore but i think i'm screwed
if anyone's ever thought of that but oh
[ __ ]
have you oh no oh wait wait really
yeah actually though the last few phone
numbers it's really easy
it takes two seconds everyone's kind of
picked up on it now
i will be deleting my accounts you have
accounts now
i've always had them but i didn't know
that people could search the number
yeah yeah [ __ ] i know i feel like if
you're
super active on it definitely they can
like okay
great let's move what's the next one
okay um linkedin
linkedin if you want to see what's
that's where they were age of that's a
different age of god yeah if you're
if you're dating someone like older and
you want to see how long they've been at
their job i kind of like when a guy is a
linkedin i'm like oh you know you can
also professional
i know and then you can see how long
they've stuck in that certain
business yeah and it also shows how
loyal they might be to you if they're
loyal to their company they're going to
be loyal to you
this next one is my jam it's so up my
alley find out when their birthday is
yeah and see if your zodiacs align i do
this all the time and i know
i know it's so cringy but it's so fun
it's so
it screams like crazy girl but i
actually do this on a date where i'll
ask a guy what their sign is
and i will do it in front of them like a
crazy stalker
and you know what you annoys me when
guys make it like oh
she asked me with zodiac sign like all
right get over it it's just a question
it's for fun like no i mean look i know
why is there such a negative there's
such a negative connotation
and guess what guess what i've gone out
with a guy before
where he was just like that in the
beginning and then
a week later was so invested in it
thought it was so much fun
was like finding out what his moon and
his rights is
fun and if you associate it with being
oh you're into that
weirdo astrology like whatever it's
supposed to be silly and fun i don't
believe it 100 percent
but like to talk about a good
conversation yeah because if you're both
like
matching it's just it's fun but then if
you're not i do
i do take it to heart i mean it's kind
of cool we we talked about this
yesterday with
megan fox and mgk how they're twin
flames yes but it's because
their sun moon and rising are i think
exactly the same
which is pretty cool i've never met
anyone that's exactly that's the same
thing as me
okay next one it's my friend oh my
friend told me this
find their yelp account because if they
have one then that means they're a
complainer and you don't want to date
a yelp a counter count a helper a yelper
a yeah not a yelp account see if they
have a yelp account
and if they do they're a complainer yeah
that is
hysterical okay um wait your friend also
said one about a gofundme
funny she wrote gofundme to see if
they're competing for a charity
with a good soul i can't is that so
funny i never thought of that because
they're a complainer if they have a
gofundme they're a good person
if they're like campaigning for
something maybe they're not like oh
raise money to buy me a new
car my girlfriend said a really funny
one she said
her roommates have had their boyfriend
you know on spotify
when you follow different accounts and
different people
it shows the last song like sophia
stallone listened to
yeah or the last playlist you played
yeah so the girls will look at their
boyfriend's spotify account
and see if their sex playlist was
recently played or not
what because it'll say like this
playlist
uh so and so played this playlist six
hours ago
that's so intense so smart though that's
so smart i never even thought of that i
know
oh my gosh i know wow genius
and i feel like in today's day and age
um especially with like the millennials
and gen z
a lot of people are doing like fake tick
tocks
because instagram stalking is sort of
out now it's all about the tick tocks
talking stock on tick tock yep
they're making fake tick tock accounts
and messaging their boyfriends to see if
they'll flirt back that's
manipulative that's kind of that's dirty
the dirty that's dirty
you know i have to say overall i think
these stocking techniques are hilarious
yeah yeah and so if you have a reason to
stalk him i think you already have your
answer
exactly and i was just about to preface
and say it's not healthy and i
definitely like
i'm never gonna find something yeah and
i make jokes that i do it
and i i don't do it as much anymore i
didn't go this in depth
like there wasn't times where i've maybe
one person i probably would have done
like this in depth no but it was funny
because
we just threw it out there to both of
our group chats and we said
let us know what you think like let it
rip yeah because i was like i wrote the
basics like the facebook and then the
youtube
funny thing but i'm sorry yeah girls are
really good and if you guys don't think
that guys do some of the same things
you're tripping you know we asked a guy
this if he if they stalk girls as much
as girls
stalk i mean i don't i hate the word
stock
yeah it's such an intense word what
should we call it we're not stalking
we're just
we're just saying yoo-hoo
guys un-girl yeah they definitely do
and then there goes oh no i don't go to
her page i'm like okay
um i've had a guy admit to me that he
went back
throughout my entire instagram instead
of glow up so i mean
that is that is a dirty comment that is
like the most
that's like the the best compliment and
the
best insult i've ever had i think that
was genuinely the perfect
combo of both yeah you're like i'm i was
ugly but you're telling me i'm not
anymore
thank you it's like when a guy one time
said i was quirky
and i i don't know how i kept i was like
thank you because i was like i know i am
but i don't know if i want to be called
quirky like oh you're such a
quirky girl i felt one of my [ __ ]
jess from new girl
corki um but yeah uh so have fun with
those if you want to do it
definitely don't go overboard because i
think there's also something great to
not know something about
the person see i like to figure out the
mystery the mystery is better yeah
also i think she says that she starts to
delete her
no i'm talking about i i did stop i
stopped using it but
i think that the less you know about him
the
better it ends up being because i
remember on dates where
i would go on i would be like if i knew
a lot of things about them or like knew
most things about them it just wouldn't
end up being as great as when it's
last minute and you're like don't feel
like going you don't 100 it's great
so yeah take it or leave it i need to
leave it i love that
love that on that note i think we should
wrap up the show
yes with our unsolicited advice
segment you guys we haven't done this
one in a few weeks
my favorite part of the show is the
unsolicited advice remember if you guys
want your questions answered
make sure you go to the unwaxed apple
podcast page
leave your question in the ratings and
review section give us five stars and
that is the only way
we will answer your question again also
we read all of the reviews
pretty much every day we love them thank
you so much
we read all the comments and some of you
girls have been really really really
nice
especially on my part i answered a
couple of them and you have no idea how
much that makes my day
when some girls say i relate to you i
feel like i'm listening to my best
friends because that's our goal
we just want to be the sisters you don't
have and your best friends that
don't judge you yeah look it look at us
we're on waxed we just literally share
everything and
we love that you do it with us too and
that we're able to relate so
just thanks guys okay so here is the
first question
how to tell if your partner isn't
interested
in you anymore it's really a running
theme with today's episode but
i think it just makes sense yeah it
works it works um
i don't know how to tell if your partner
isn't interested in you anymore
well the first thing i thought of was
when you have issues within the
relationship let's say there's a fight
there's a disagreement
and neither one of you is or let's just
say your partner like i'm just to say a
guy because that's
what relates to me yeah doesn't put in
the effort
to fix that he just doesn't even care at
this point so there's no more try
there's no child to fight for yeah
because you know that when someone puts
in the effort to resolve an issue
they care they care about fixing it but
when they
don't care about fixing it yeah also
it's sort of tied to that
if you have to sort of pull out
affection attention and like reassurance
from this person
instead of it just coming organically
like if you have to
constantly do things or say things or
even ask for that person to be like
can you say you love me or can you say
good night to me if you have to ask for
those things then
that's a red flag well another kind of
aggressive one is
i mean less sex and it's not aggressive
i feel like that's
i mean yeah like sexual intimacy is just
less and
it's just not maybe he i wrote down this
i said
calls you a different name and that has
happened to so many of my friends yeah
seriously that's just cheating at this
point they're just not even
in the mindset that's i can't even oh
this one's a good one
read it hide his phone and plans from
you
where he doesn't even update you about
things he's going to do
where he's going to go or he won't i
think
if if you ever phone out like i want one
to grab a guy's phone
and go through anything i honestly i
respect that like my phone's my phone
your phone is your phone
like i don't have any trust issues when
it comes out yeah but
if a guy ever asked to see my phone i'd
be like all right go ahead
like look i know so i mean at the end of
the day
if you already feel like your partner
isn't interested in
in you anymore and you have to even ask
this question i think you know the
answer
my advice get out first
run break up with him first yeah you
want to say that you broke up with him
yes you're a bad [ __ ] and you got a lot
of things you want to offer
you got a lot of things you can offer to
a lot of great guys
hey hot girl summer is coming up and
guess what do not
waste your time on people that don't put
in time for you
or don't invest time with you yeah you
know what you deserve love
yeah if they're not giving that as much
as you are then it's not worth it so
from unwaxed
we tell you put on your running shoes
and [ __ ] sprint sprints run away
maybe the healthy way is to say maybe
bring up an open communication and just
say
no there's something lacking here but
you know what if that doesn't work
the mature thing doesn't work join us in
the summer
put on your nikes and get the [ __ ] out
get out of there just take your carry-on
and dip
she's a runner she's a truck stop oh
this is such a fun episode i think this
is
yeah i honestly i love talking about
dating and guys and these funny stories
and those
bleed makeouts remember if you guys want
to have
your questions answered for unsolicited
advice
leave them in the ratings review section
submit us your bedtime stories
again we'd love doing this every tuesday
make sure you're subscribed
follow us on tik tok follow us on
instagram also we have exciting news
we're actually bringing back on
a guest yes so we are
shooting an episode in a couple days
that we're going to release next tuesday
and it's amazing amazing amazing woman
that we're having on that sistine
i i don't know how you did it but they
manifested this one
really and it's going to be super super
cool and a very very interesting episode
i'm really excited i know i miss guests
we started our show with having a guest
every single week and i think we've done
about six shows without a guest so it's
really exciting to sort of
bring that energy back and i think we're
to do it a few more times
like the next few episodes are going to
be yes so i hope you guys
are looking forward to that because we
are join us next week
and we'll see you bye bye from all of us
here at the show
thanks for staying on waxed wax
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts at sophia stallone
and at sistine stallone and be sure to
follow the show at
unwax podcast your producer is will
sterling
we'll see you next week